[Music]
nothing else to report and as we'd been
banned from the press gaggle and labeled
as fake news by the president
we'll have to prove them wrong Thanks
Trump's approval numbers have gone to
new lows according to a new poll and
we're never wrong about those and his
Starbucks new cup bringing people to
tears no but we'll find two tweets like
we do every year and if this is
obviously bad but do you think you can
maybe help our case a tad they say we're
not news that we just make stuff up
my apologies sim I'll fix that right up
a nurse shark that a man and a florida
park could this summer be the summer of
sharp loss of product you own causes
death exponentially the answer to that
misleading question event as you're
hiding the cause of acute meningitis do
you see why perhaps there are folks who
don't like it I really believe that
they're flatly just wrong but you just
helped me a little can do cabochons well
a hero was born with the daring AG who
will enforce laws with which she
disagrees lust Kim Davis the
mouth-breathing slob should we jail
public servants who won't do their jobs
see that's what I mean that's what they
accused that we color the coverage to
match with our views should we not be
objective and foster a truck I suppose
you write to him I'll do what I must a
world on the brink perils unfurled as
Trump speaks with the most dangerous man
in the world was Mitt Romney's gas just
don't seem to slow the moronic claim
Russia is our biggest foe and finally
it's given all journalists supers but
proof has been found by
PricewaterhouseCoopers the president
making with great genuflecting
concessions to rush Ivy wins the
election
[Music]
a white house in chaos will give you a
peek at the transcripts we got from a
delightful new league but Edward Snowden
the traitor of Raj hood leakers be hung
like the cowards they are
[Music]